girl i'm loving this you're giving me
like audrey hepburn vibes right now was
that the intention we were just turning
it out for season two you know a little
valentino number a little bright ball of
fun
and i love it and that's exactly what we
can expect from season two of emily in
paris we have work drama we have love
triangles give me your best season two
teas because so much happens a lot of
love geometry that's what i keep saying
i'm like it's all all shapes all
triangle rectangle square um a lot more
french culture french language drama
laughs fashion all of the above
friendships female friendships
it used to be so decisive and ever since
i moved to paris my life has just been
chaotic and dramatic and complicated
oh emily you're getting more french by
the day i love that not only are you our
emily you're also a producer on the
series and what i love is that you've
been really outspoken about some of the
criticism or backlash that emily paris
has faced when it came to season two
what were you doing behind the scenes to
kind of address some of those changes
and what you wanted to see i think all
of us you know creatives a part of the
show knew that if we were given the
opportunity for a second season we
wanted to have emily immerse herself
more in the french culture the more of
the french language embracing more of
the fabric that makes up the city of
paris which is the people she meets the
food she eats the language she speaks
all of the above and we always knew that
if we got to go to a second season
that's where it would go and we were
just hoping that we would get to so we
were part of all those conversations and
choices and new cast members which we're
so excited about
you've got the rest of your life to be
as dull as you wish
but while you're here
fall in love
make mistakes
if you're gonna do paris for one year
for god's sake do it right we can't talk
about emily and paris without talking
about the amazing fashion talk to me
about the behind the scenes of it all
from the initial fittings to putting it
on the air about how long is that
process oh my god my first fitting for
the season i think was about seven hours
um you walk into a room and it's just
covered with fabric and colors and
prints and designs um
so much fun we collaborate on every
outfit every scene i mean every episode
has about
10 outfits so it takes a lot of time to
get those right but um it's fun it's
also really
hard to wear that many layers sometimes
um and running around the streets in
heels especially after a cobit having
worn sweatpants for a year and a half
being comfortable and all of a sudden
it's like oh fashion what is that
like oh heels that's right i am not this
small much taller than normal
um did anything from the wardrobe closet
lily accidentally happened to come home
with you
um from season one maybe a couple items
season two i didn't get so lucky
did not get so lucky you know i really
wanted half of kami's wardrobe to be
honest i was really really into some of
her boots this season um yeah i think if
we get to go to a season three i'm
definitely gonna try to write that in
need the closet
and lastly congratulations on your
wedding thank you how are you gonna
spend your first holiday as a wife
ooh um with our little dog redford and
family lots of family